[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima welcome to
ET lives right i'm danny director we're
here to give you guys a full recap of
the Golden Globe Awards that just
happened right now oh my gosh you guys I
was on the red carpet talking to as many
people as I could flag down and Denny
has been a glued to the TV so we know
exactly what happened for the past few
hours we're gonna go through the biggest
moments the surprises snubs of the night
but of course we want to know what you
think how did you feel about the times
that movemen about the winners let us
know in the comments we will get them
right here so I know you want to lead us
on I mean I think it's the most talked
about moment right now from the Golden
Globe Awards and I'm talking about of
course
Oprah's powerful Cecil B DeMille
acceptance speech I mean she truly
brought down the house and really took
the moment to send a very powerful
message to everyone watching and in case
you missed it we have a quick little
look for you now for too long women have
not been heard or believed if they dared
to speak their truth to the power of
those men but their time is up
Oprah right there of course talking
about the times that movement she really
paid tribute to all the women affected
by sexual abuse and she took the moment
to really send out a message of hope in
my opinion I'm telling you she's always
been a wealth of wisdom right but no I
feel like we needed her words now more
than ever especially in that moment I
think this speaks to and kind of
summarizes exactly what an incredibly
special night this was Frances McDormand
won at the end of the night for a Best
Actress in a Motion Picture Drama and
she said you know you can feel what's
happening here tonight and I think we
could feel it through the screen because
75th annual Golden Globe Awards
Oprah first black woman to get that
prestigious assess will be deMille Award
and of all people Oprah this incredibly
iconic woman to get it on a night when
the times that movement is in the room
and when women are talking about
bringing women to the forefront it was
like everything came together so
beautifully and honestly that's what I
love so much about that speech is she
really I mean she touched on every base
right not only did she speak to the
times that movement but she put it in
historical context how significant that
moment for her was you know she talked
about Sidney Poitier watching him except
the Cecil B deMille Award and her
realizing in that moment
that young girls are watching her be the
first african-american woman to accept
the same honor
I mean jewels shoes and I think that's
why on Twitter very quickly it started
trending you know Oprah for president
2020
I said Meyers even made a joke about it
he said something like Oprah's gonna be
President and Tom Hanks can be her VP so
I talked to Gayle King of course Oprah's
bestie on the red carpet and I love this
she said let me tell you this Oprah was
still working on her speech in the car
on the way to the Globes that's what a
perfectionist Oprah is and she said that
yesterday at rehearsal they told her
Oprah you need to cut through too long
right three minutes you guys can't tell
Oprah to shave her speech down I mean I
will say she got a varied well deserving
standing ovation and she even wanted
them to sit down cuz I think she knew
she had a lot to say she had to get it
out there and I mean really it struck a
chord with a lot of people not only in
the audience not only at the office but
I think all of you guys watching at home
- absolutely yeah and so many great
women in the room I mean Reese
Witherspoon introduced and gave that
award to her they worked on the movie a
wrinkle in time together and so many
great women in that movie and Reese
Witherspoon was really the one
spearheading time's up you guys it's
just all so copacetic amazing amazing
emotional speech I can't say enough oh I
can't also say enough about the little
moment that came right after her speech
almost forgot about this you guys so the
times up movement was a thread and again
bringing women to the forefront was a
focus of the night and Natalie Portman
has Twitter and social media on fire
with this little quip right after
Oprah's speech Natalie comes out with
Ron Howard and they're about to
introduce some nominees and here's what
Natalie Portman's it and here are the
all-male nominees
but the shape of water Guillermo del
Toro I gotta say I felt for guillermo
del toro because he's the first nominee
read from the list and the first person
a show on camera after she makes that
quip she's of course referencing the
fact that no female directors were
nominated this year for a Golden Globe
yeah it was a big deal this year I
talked to Lori Metcalfe on the carpet
she's an of course Lady Bird which if
I'm correct still holds the record it
definitely broke the record as being the
best reviewed movie honest aggregator
Rotten Tomatoes of all time
and Greta Gerwig did not get a Best
Director nomination for that a lot of
people spoke to the fact that patty
Jenkins didn't get a nomination for
Wonder Woman Laurie Metcalf straight up
told me on the red carpet I was really
disappointed in that news and so Oprah
just gives this great speech and then
Natalie Portman comes out and says and
here are the nominees they're all men by
the way Natalie Portman standing next to
a very acclaimed
male director I mean power to her for
speaking up and especially because it's
so hard to follow that speech that Oprah
gave but again I just felt a little bad
for Gilmore del Toro you know she can't
control of course and all the and all
the male directors you could see there
as they panned each one on their faces
fell a little bit and look they're all
incredibly talented made some incredibly
amazing movies this year of course and
the nominations are always a tight tight
race but again it's just something had
to be called out tonight something that
would be called tonight and I think a
lot of people had a lot to say and I
just have to give props to Seth Meyers I
thought he was just the perfect host for
this year's Golden Globes obviously he's
always found that balance between
politics and comedy and he did that in
his monologue this year don't you think
I thought it was borderline to
perfection I mean look I get that when
you're dealing with the subject matter
he's dealing with some people and might
have felt that he went a little too far
points but every time it felt like he
went a little too far he acknowledged it
he said okay okay you know way if you
thought that was bad let me now say this
he was the perfect choice to me to
balance like you said the political feel
and the issues in the room with bringing
some comedy and some levity to it this
could not address it oh you couldn't not
you could or not he maybe maybe went too
far again at some moments up let's take
a listen here well I think it's time to
address the elephant not in the room
Harvey Weinstein isn't here tonight
because well I've heard rumors that he's
crazy and difficult to work with he went
for it he made jokes about Harvey
Weinstein about Kevin Spacey he said the
names and I have to say I think that
there there was a bold thought behind
that and I felt like overall his mana on
really really worked because he like he
said it's the elephant in the room
everybody in Hollywood knew these people
he just announced it he also didn't
waste any time which I appreciated you
don't he's like let's just get right to
it he didn't hold anything back and I
don't think the host of the Golden
Globes after this particular moment in
time should hold back you know to me so
I thought and of course this is a
Hollywood event honoring other people in
Hollywood how could you not bring up
Harvey Weinstein you know what I mean
and he did so I thought so effortlessly
and so hilariously and also you know he
did at the same time acknowledge all the
women all the powerful women in that
room so I like I said I thought it was
balanced and he hit all the poky struck
all the right chords I thought it was
all so perfect that he even said I get
that I'm a male hosting this show you
know he made a joke about that several
jokes actually he said I get it I'm like
a straight white guy up here hosting the
show and what we're really talking about
tonight is bringing more diversity to
this show so he acknowledged it and oh
here it comes the love for Oprah tweets
from you guys Amen - Oprah from from M
Davidson Mike demure says Oprah 2020 she
has so she doesn't want to run oh you
guys and we're actually just hearing
this now so we've got an amazing little
et group text where we're literally
we've got people at all the different
parties all night long huge and by the
way we'll bring you the behind the
scenes info but Amie Kaufman who's a
friend of mine a reporter from the LA
Times just tweeted that she asked
Stedman if Oprah would run for president
and Steinman's said quote it's up to the
people oh he would absolutely do it well
in that case I changed my mind
Oprah we need you we desperately need
you ha ha I mean come on okay well she's
she's a woman of the people you know you
know you mentioned a lot of people had
something to say so me I opened in her
speech that she also acknowledged was
the men in the room who are also
listening who are not only staying there
in solidarity but they're listening and
you know we have to acknowledge some
really good men who were honored tonight
there's a lot of amazing amazing people
who walked across that stage and gave
some very powerful speeches I want to
talk about one history maker the
year sterling K Brown he accepted the
Golden Globe for Best Actor in a Drama
TV series for this is us and he actually
made history becoming the first
african-american man to accept that
trophy which one is in a period that's a
feat in itself but when we talked to him
on the red carpet I also wore a pen
basically to acknowledge that he is
ready and looking forward to projects
that are written directed produced and
starring women in fact he told us who
his dream which female director he would
dream to work with take a life
but the director of Wonder Woman which
was one of my favorite films of the year
so Kim that would be excited all right
okay so let's talk about this patty
Jenkins how did you
you know what story you're gonna to get
a line dog there are a lot of people who
want to work with patty Jenkins but that
was at the top of his list he also
mentioned Regina King had directed an
episode of this is us and she was
sensational but he said that he's really
driven and motivated by stories from a
female perspective and that's kind of
it's a powerful message descent
especially right now I have to say I
talked to so many men tonight first of
all every single one of them was wearing
black and again if you guys didn't know
it was just a message sent through
Hollywood that everybody was gonna wear
black tonight in solidarity with women
and a lot of people worrying those times
up pins which is actually for The Times
up Legal Defense Fund started by some
really strong women in Hollywood
including Reese Witherspoon who had the
piece designed for tonight so it's just
a cool night but you have so many men I
mean you know I talked to Hugh Jackman
and he said I actually heard about all
this through the press I I didn't have
any like Hollywood best friend who gave
me a call but I said of course I'm
getting in on this
he had the pen you know Justin Hartley
from this is us as they're talking about
hey I've got a 13 year old daughter I'm
raising my wife my amazing female
co-stars it was so many men saying
tonight is about them and putting the
focus on those other women on those
women and it was really like I cried on
the red carpet it was awesome it's an
emotional moment I think that's why they
all wanted to wear black because they
said this is not a fashion moment
anymore this is a moment in history a
moment in time where everyone men and
women can stand in solidarity for what's
going on and so I thought it was really
amazing and a tribute to all those
people who are fighting the good fight
and using their voices for good
absolutely I'm so we
had some history-makers some record
breakers tonight including sterling K
Brown a record that probably should have
been broken a long time ago but let's
talk a little bit about this show that
keeps on just racking up those
nominations big little lies you guys oh
yes we do stands for a very long time
just like they've been in the worth
award circuit just for a very long time
the Emmys first Golden Globes are headed
to the SAG Awards all deserving and of
course Nicole Kidman another amazing
speech she kicked off the night actually
Nicole Kidman had the first speech of
the night winning a Best Actress and I
just don't think Nicole Kidman can make
a misstep in a speech IgG online.com
will really break down Nicole speech but
I mean she thanked her daughter's her
mother her husband people who she works
with the director the producers her
co-stars and fellow producers like Reese
Witherspoon and did it all so eloquently
I mean I cried during Nicole speech I
cried a couple times tonight you know I
will say about a call so she loves her
husband so much and she saved that last
bit of her speech for him they like to
remind me how single I am like they're
just so in love and but not just so in
love but the words they have for each
other in moments like that added at an
award show during an acceptance speech
it's so touching you guys and also we
talked to them on the red carpet cute as
can be of course but here's a little
glimpse of what we can expect from big
little lies season two
courtesy of Nicole I mean for us right
now this is about bigger lies this is
about celebrating what we did for some I
mean it took a number of years to get
this project made and to have had the
fans in the audience react in the way
that they have to gosh crazy right we'll
the second series literally because of
the audience's desire we went oh my gosh
we got to scramble and try and get this
together if we want you to do a season
two and we all kind of put down put our
heads together and when yeah let's try
to do it but that was because of the
audiences and the critical response to
this show I think I was embarrassingly
begging you last or ceremony okay let's
do it and hopefully we will create more
opportunities for women I mean I'm going
back to work on Tuesday with a female
director so there's also
female JP a first assistant director
who's female so in that sense you know
that's I'm trying to do my bit they're
doing their bit he's doing her bit to do
her bit so big little eyes season two
has been so talked about for so many
reasons one because there was even some
controversy around the show people
saying well why is it nominated as a
limited series but the creator said hey
we didn't know who's gonna get a second
season when we were figuring all this
out so I talked to the director
jean-marc vallée on the red carpet and I
said to him why did you do this to me
you are not directing the second season
because I've talked to Nicole Kidman
before and she said he just brings this
cinematic quality to the series and he
said he's really busy with his new show
sharp objects and also he's still gonna
be a producer so he's going to be still
part of things still bringing that same
big little lies tone that we loved about
the show but clearly because nicole says
that they're also reaching out to a lot
of females to directed to write it they
have a DP who's female I'm also hoping
that they actually introduce some new
characters and we get some other
actresses you know so maybe some of
their friends I know named Naomi Watts
has talked about she would love to play
with them on big little ice season too
so here's holding out for that by the
way I depressed
I pressed jean-marc vallée for some
spoilers and he wouldn't give me any
except for one which will be up at 8:00
a.m. I'm calm I'm teasing you guys that
he gave me a season two spoiler that
made me a little bit shaky so clay Brice
more comments tweeters are coming in
clay says he was upset the post didn't
win anything but here's hoping for the
Oscars you want to take a couple of
these oh my god
cereal burrito first of all you have a
great Twitter handle he says comig
Lachlan was robbed
you know twin peaks at least got in
there with that nomination you know what
it's a revival but you know they all
can't be winners in fact there are so
there were quite a few snows and
surprises I mean the post was kind of
funny because you think Spielberg Streep
Hanks Hey Adri Seth Meyers monologue
when he mentioned the post and Spielberg
and Hanks and Streep the Globes keynote
on I get no joke about a doubt but they
did not walk away why did sauce monster
says it was a good show agreed so let's
get into some of these snubs and
surprises and want to remind you guys ET
is backstage so we're talking to the
winners right when they come off the
carpet right now we're also going to
beat all the after-party so you can
check that out at ET online comment
Amaro night on ET of course to get all
the BT
but the snobs surprises first of all a
lot of wins for three billboards outside
Epping Missouri which i think is a
surprise I think it was a surprise
especially because you guys watched our
preview we predicted that shape of water
would take it that did not happen
shape of water hit the most nominees you
have the most nominations how to exactly
had a lot of momentum going into this
race but three billboards took your
Frances McDorman I walked away with the
Best Actress trophy
I watched it is a very amazing movie I
think I was surprised it won based on on
the love that the hfp a who votes for
the Golden Globes has previously given
Guillermo del Toro the director of shape
of water
that being said I'm like I think they
did kind of spread the love I think a
lot of people are surprised three
billboards won Best Screenplay and not
Lady Bird and Sam Rockwell also won for
three billboard what can be amazing
about this awards show love that's
unexpected is that a really good movie
then gets more eyes on it because you
know now everybody's seeing that it's
getting these awards and maybe you go
and check it out and Frances McDormand
speech towards the end of the night
there when she won Best Actress and a
Motion Picture Drama I was delirious I
mean she just got up there pretty casual
about it
thanks for Cowboys woody and Sam and she
said the women in the room are not here
for the food
they're here for the work so three of
billboards definitely a little bit of a
surprise and those surprises always lead
to what people to consider to be snobs
another snob not to do a three
billboards but Gary Oldman one and a lot
of people said that call me by your
names start Timothy a showman well that
being said you know Timothy is this is
breakthrough year he's got many years
ahead he's got time to collect that
globe gary oldman on the other hand has
been around for a while he's finally
getting some do for his performance in
the darkest hour so I'm at the while I
feel Timothy was wrong I'm also not
surprised at the honoring Gary in this
way he might even take it all the way
the Oscars it's you know that they were
kind of honoring his career in that
sense you know they always they always
do that Kate Winslet finally won a
Golden Globe out there look like 20
nomination it took a minute
took a minute ya know Timothy's
performance has been so critically
acclaimed there's a funny little viral
moment if you guys want to check it out
on Twitter when Timothy sha'lame
seemingly realizes that Tonya Harding
was today nice to him and he's like oh
that's hard
you know a speaking of Tonya Harding
there were a lot of a lot of movies a
lot of biopics about real people and
they were actually in the room so Tonya
Harding was one of them another surprise
tonight was after James Franco won for
the disaster artist he brought up the
real Tommy Wiseau to the stage who by
the way was trying to jack the mic from
James Franco if you guys miss anchor and
James yeah I have something saying I got
offended that like my cat that Kanye
moment to happen yeah yeah Tommy was
walking the red carpet having his moment
and I heard him say to a lot of people
who said you know I think James did a
good job with this movie he was the
perfect person to play the part so it
it's awkward when the real people are in
the room sometimes I live for those
moments during the Golden Globes though
you know we need we kind of needed that
levity I was cracking up yeah I mean if
you guys haven't seen it--on yet by the
way Allison Janney won tonight
and she told me on the carpet that she
this part was actually written for her
like with her in mind even though it's a
real world part her friend who's a
writer wrote the part thinking she could
play this and they had been trying to
work together for so long she teared up
in our interview because she said
finally I got to work with him and all
of this has come out of it I Tania was
like start to finish me in less than a
year or something crazy like that so
that movie has been this awards show
I don't know blockbuster we're kind of
just moving bus out of nowhere and it's
really been awesome to see especially a
movie like that with the such a small
budget it's moments like this that
really get a lot more people in those
seats people are going to see that movie
and you you know Allison Janney actually
mentioned how she shot her part which
she won tonight as well shot her part in
eight days eight days it's it's kind of
incredible to watch though and I love
that time yet it was so funny okay again
guys please let us know what you thought
if there are any movies you wanted to
see get more Awards we see the post in
there for clay or any movies that you
thought really really deserved the
accolades they got tonight you talked
about Lady Bird people being surprised
that that didn't win a little more and
again we said gret people were surprised
Greta Gerwig did not get nominated but
it was great to see her get up there and
say have a moment for Best Comedy right
oh yes yes ELISA Lady Bird winning best
comedy and Greta was so flustered and
overwhelmed and you could tell this is
such a personal project it was her
directorial debut and also was such a
personal story so they she related to
she's from Sacramento and it's kind of
nice to see those little indie darlings
walk across that stage and accept the
trophies like that yeah yeah it's
awesome
we are gonna wrap it down here but again
I just want to say overall I thought it
was such an authentic night for it being
the 75th Golden Globes what a great
night to bring up this times up movement
to bring up women and diversity and
everybody felt so genuine
I felt so emotional and I think you
could really tell even through our
screens we could tell there was an
energy in the room and I have to admit I
wasn't sure about what the energy in
that room would be I thought the tone
would be a little more down but you know
what there it was a nice balance and
more than anything I walked away feeling
empowered watching that award show so I
think Golden Globes are really setting
the tone for the rest of this awards
season so we'll see what happens when
all goes down of course et online.com
will be tracking these award shows up
until the Oscars you guys it's gonna be
a busy busy quarters yes again had two
easy online comm for behind-the-scenes
moments including if you haven't seen it
yet Tom Hanks with a tray of martinis
for his table guys the globe has the
booze in the room so the fun is brought
man after my own heart
so behind-the-scenes moments at et
online.com we are literally still at the
after parties like HBO's big afterparty
interviewing people tracking them down
we're in the room a scene everything
that's really going on so we're gonna
bring that all to you guys and watch
tomorrow night on ET for the deets as
well I think you guys for tuning in
today all right we're out good night
[Music]
you